let's get reaction now to this from
currency expert Leia holpen who is the
author of the best-selling book
undressing Bitcoin she's also the star
of the popular Leia holpen show on
YouTube hi Leah welcome to the show
hi great to be here thank you so much
for having me uh great to have you uh
back on the program have I overstated
the threat to our freedoms of a cashless
Society
no I think he stated it perfectly Mark
um you know you say you think this is
part of a greater campaign to move us
onto a central bank digital currency and
I totally agree with you you're
absolutely right because right now we're
living through many different woke
climate crisis agendas we you know we've
gone from covid we're now on to the
climate process whatever it is and they
need people to comply with their agenda
during covert I believe they overstepped
their Mark when people have had enough
they won't take their boosters anymore
um but they need people to start
complying and how do they do that they
do that with their money because once
you control the money you control the
world and like you said that money will
be programmable and so right now they
want us to start tracking our carbon
they want to implement some sort of
carbon allowance and how do you do that
with the money you program the money so
Mark say you want to have a barbecue
when the summer finally comes in the UK
and you know you want to buy some
sausages some meat whatever it is you
could actually reach your carbon
allowance so that the next week when you
go to fill up your car with gas well
your money gets declined because you've
reached your carbon so it essentially
allows you and allows them to control
every little thing that we do and it is
so concerning because money money is
really just the energy which fuels your
life so if you don't have control over
your money well you don't really have
control over anything
isn't this a bit of a conspiracy theory
though it might happen in China but not
in a free country like Britain or the
United States
you know it's so funny when people say
that because right now the West copy
everything that China does they admire
it Justin Trudeau talks about China as
if it's this incredible country and how
he really values everything China does
we copied their covert response and we
are copying their cbdc response we saw
it with Rishi sunaki so excited about
britcoin right now nine more than 90 of
world banks are all working towards a
cbdc and actually one of the biggest
issues here is the lack of privacy
because like you said you know if you
say the wrong thing or you like the
wrong thing on social media they will
know that it's you they will be able to
control your money and switch it off
this is why I'm a huge advocate for not
only Bitcoin but privacy coins privacy
points where it's entirely Anonymous and
also you can't track it and there are
many different people working on this
whether it's somebody like Tommy net who
are building a decentralized internet
they're also building a decentralized
privacy coin and so these sorts of
things Bitcoin and privacy coins I look
at as the solution to a CBD DC okay and
I hear you've got those options but do
you think that actually a cashless
Society is inevitable and it will be
replaced by things like Bitcoin and
these other Solutions do you think that
cash will be a thing of the past
unfortunately I do think hash will be a
thing of the past and I know you did say
cash is King I don't necessarily it has
to be a bad
point and like privacy coins these
things will these things are inevitable
we are living in a new digital world
right now where people are doing
business with people globally global
trade and so we desperately do need an
alternative to actually cater for this
new digital world whether you like cash
or not I do think it will be a thing of
the past but as long as we do have
things like Bitcoin and privacy poems
like Tommy a building then I think we
will be protected to a greater extent my
thanks to Leia Halpin who is the star of
the Leia helping show on YouTube she's
got a huge number of subscribers do go
on YouTube and find out why she's on
Twitter as well